The jogan Experience what do you think
about all this UAP UFO stuff oh
[__] you know I don't know it's
something it's something I don't know
what it is some of it is like some
people theorize it's like plasma
Technologies but they're like they're
getting physical signatures on it you
know you're getting like the all the
radar return signatures and you're
getting like infrared you know I don't I
don't [__] know man I mean it's
really blows me away I keep cuz I can't
say I can't say for sure like I believe
that that other life forms exist um I
also believe I just don't know if it's
like it doesn't make any sense why
they're like let's just hang out never
show ourselves and just do like really
cool tricky stuff and have people get a
bunch of blurry images of it that we can
never [__] see yeah that's that's the
weird thing but I don't know what it is
man I mean it's either natural
phenomenon or it's something that's been
here a long time um or they probes uh
from that are triggered by a certain I
don't know
technological escalation in human
society or they're somehow ours but that
doesn't make any sense either I don't
know man I mean I've seen them I've seen
I've seen UFOs but yeah I might have
mentioned on the show before but I've
seen like the classic like three glowing
spheres in the distance kind of moving
along and like a search light turning on
or a spotlight turning on turning off
and then like gliding with no noise in a
canyon i' I've seen that but and that
was awe inspiring but you know some of
the footage that you see you're like
that is what is that it just went into
the ocean it just went into the ocean at
the same it's still traveling at the
same rate that it was traveling in the
air and they're they're recording it so
it's either like a huge hoax which
doesn't make any sense because people
talk or they're I don't know man or it's
like interdimensional
[__] it's uh uh maybe if we are in a
simulation there like glitches in the
simulation you know like there's like
other things bleeding through and like
we're seeing things that don't have any
um that don't that don't um adhere to
the laws of physics because they aren't
really in our Physical Realm in a way I
don't I don't really know because I I
just it it really it baffles me and then
also when the government starts
releasing stuff and then you got a guy
going around like well you know I've
been cleared by the you know whatever
CIA or whatever to be able to talk about
this and all the stuff like you been
cleared to talk about stuff that you're
supposed to not be talking about is a
weird that's weird and then I'm like is
it propaganda is it like I don't know
man it's it's a it's a tough one because
I grew up like I love UFOs like I grew
up Project Blue Book watch the series
loved aliens used to sit in my backyard
looking up at the stars hoping that I
would see an alien one day and then I
did see not aliens but I saw U uips or
UFOs where were you when you saw that I
was in Montana I was like probably 177
and uh it was we were camping and uh at
at night and then we decided to to climb
a but in the middle of the night so we
were crossing a big cattle field and
then I was walking and two friends were
ahead of me and I kind of just looked to
my right stopped looked to my right and
I just saw these in the distance I don't
know how far it would be but like you
know they looked like about that big
from my perspective so down a ways and
there were three of them it wasn't one
object because they change they would
change distance from each other and
change elevation a little bit really low
and then at some point sometimes it
would just stop and you'd see a little
beam turn on turn off and then it would
start to move again it was really really
weird I had two friends I I kept looking
at I was like come here CU I didn't want
to not look and then look back and then
they weren't there type of movie [__]
but my friends came back and they look
down and they they describe I didn't
even tell them what I was looking at I
said tell me what you see they described
what I was seeing I don't know what it
was wow but I've heard other stories
about
relights um same kind of [__] I when I'm
watching like UFO whatever documentary
stuff I give me chills because I'm like
I've seen that whatever that is I've
seen that so I don't know I don't know
man it's like I go my mind goes all over
the place but there's no
definitive no cuz no one's you know it's
like unless they land and you're like oh
right there it is or we see not the
Mexico City alien right like obviously a
joke
um not a joke but whatever it was a hoax
like unless we get something where it's
like oh [__] what is that what is this
metal or you know the scientists saying
that they found a piece of a an alien
ship at the bottom of the ocean because
it's material they can't
identify um I don't know it's it's weird
I'm excited about it I think it's kind
of interesting and I'm hopeful but it's
almost like the more information that
gets released the more I'm like I don't
know what to think I'm exactly where you
are yeah but I I think more than likely
that a lot of what we're seeing a lot of
these people are seeing is some sort of
top secret probe with some sort of super
sophisticated propulsion system that
doesn't rely on a combustion engine some
completely new style of propulsion
system that they've been working on
they've been working on gravity
propulsion System since the 1950s true
they've been at least theorizing these
things and the the possibility that
someone has come up with something in a
drone form that they can pilot like that
makes the most sense to me because they
keep spotting these things in areas
where the military practices they keep
spotting these things off the coast of
San Diego off the east coast where they
have this these uh restricted areas
that's where they're seeing these things
like it just makes sense that that would
be where they would practice these
things but what's weird about it is that
you know like there was that famous UFO
Crossing incident over the northern all
the uh States so going from I think
Seattle or Washington all the way Idaho
Montana North Dakota they were chasing
the Squadron of unidentified flying
objects in the 50s the 50s 50s so that's
the one thing that because you do hear
about sightings like even in the 1800s
you know 17 that's the weird thing right
that's the that's the thing where I'm
like well if it's true but I mean in the
50s I mean there's like shots of it
there's people took photographs of these
like Squadron of
glowing discs and they were kept and
they were going so fast that Jets
couldn't keep up with him so I had to
scramble Jets at the next base and they
our baseball team is called are called
the voyagers based off of that incident
really yeah so I mean in Great Falls but
like I don't know that that's the weird
thing about it I mean I do I agree with
you I think there is some kind of like
propulsion system and that you know is
able to like change on a dime and like
doesn't necessarily get affected in the
way that normal so there's probably
multiple things going on simultan that's
what I'm saying yeah I I do not doubt
that we've been visited if there is
intelligent life that's capable of
coming here from somewhere else of
course they would I mean well that's the
place you would go yeah exactly I mean
it's like it seems like in a way I just
feel like the Earth is kind of like a a
terrarium it's like it's like they're
just like let's do a pilot program here
throw some seeds down there monitor it
see how it goes certainly could be I
mean some people think the Moon is a
spaceship well those people might be
dumb well but they there is some there's
some well are you familiar with the Y
files you know those guy that guy y
files the Y files so it's a YouTube
channel this dude he he's he's he he
basically just re he recounts stories of
paranormal um whether it's uh you know
occult stuff spiritual stuff but U not
spiritual stuff but just like ghost
stuff or aliens um or interdimensional
travel that type of stuff and then he
talks he tells the story and kind of
reenacts and then at the end he kind of
De debunks it or tries to debunk it but
he seems to be pretty impartial but he
was talking about how like when they
landed on the moon they did they they
basically did seismic tests and the
reverberance there was a reverberance
that would indicate that it's possibly
Hollow and it's it does sound like a
far-fetched thing but there there is a
lot of there's some kind of interesting
things there again I'm not like a firm
believer in it but but if you think of
it in a Fantastical way like what if
that was a spaceship that just like idle
lot you know just they just stopped that
spaceship did some experiments on Earth
or whatever and just left the spaceship
there I don't know I don't know I'm dumb
hi guys how are you that one seems so
stupid I know but it's it's fun to look
into